how are you greeted by cristian casseres with
informative hat from news now in
spanish I tell you that in you zbik will
collaborate with the authorities of the north
las pegues in investigation of the
fatal accident last Saturday 9
people died after a
driver passed a red light
At more than 100 miles per hour, if it is, he
tells me that he wants to understand how it happened and
that he wants to help the department to
prevent similar tragedies. Seven of
the nine victims belonged to the
same family. To find out more
about this news, you can go to
our page.  with the woman who
lost her stepchildren and brother
because of this accident
with these devices from kobe 19
declining in the state the driver
decided to close two window testing sites
party a gender will be closed
on wednesday while taxi station will
work until  February 20
however there are other sites available
throughout the valley for a list  complete you
can visit our page at inau
dotcom in the spanish section and
look for the kobe 19 vaccination and
testing sites here in las
vegas las vegas have a new
general manager and coach we talk about the
fighter iv just made years they were
introduced from  officially Monday they
both come from the pits the wind great
welcome greetings and we close with
the weather forecast we will have
warm temperatures for the afternoon
reaching 60 degrees however
for the night a cold wave will come
these winds will go away by Wednesday
I am  cristian who approached on
informative of ignition spanish good day
[Music]